so we have a quadratic expression here x
squared minus 3x minus 10. and what i'd
like to do in this video is i'd like to
factor it as the product of two
binomials or to put it another way
i want to write it as the product
x plus a that's one binomial times x
plus b where we need to figure out what
a and b are going to be so i encourage
you to pause the video and see if you
can figure out what a and b need to be
can we rewrite this expression as a
product of two binomials where we know
what a and b are
so let's work through this together now
and i'll i'll highlight a and b in
different colors i'll put a in
yellow and i'll put b in magenta
so if you one way to think about it so
let's just multiply these two binomials
using a and b and we've done this in
previous videos you might want to review
multiplying binomials if any of this
looks strange to you but if you were to
multiply what we have on the right hand
side out it would be equal to
you're going to have the x times the x
which is going to be x squared
then you are going to have the a times
the x which is ax and then you're going
to have the b times the x which is bx
actually let me just i'm not going to
skip any steps here just to see it this
time this is all review or it should be
review so then we have so we did x times
x to get x squared then we have a times
x to get
ax
to get a x and then we're going to have
x times b so we're multiplying each term
times every other term so now we have x
times b to get b x
so plus
b x
be
x
and then finally we have plus the a
times the b which is of course going to
be
a
a b
and now we can simplify this and you
might have been able to go straight to
this if you are familiar with
multiplying binomials this would be x
squared plus we can add these two
coefficients because they're both on the
first degree terms they're both
multiplied by x if i have a x's and i
add b x's to that i'm going to have a
plus b
x's
so let me write that down a
plus
b
x's and then finally i have the
plus
let me do that blue color finally i have
it as plus a b
plus
a b and now we can use this
and now we can use this to think about
what a and b need to be if we do a
little bit of pattern matching we see we
have an x squared there we have an x
squared there
we have
something we have something times x in
this case it's a negative 3 times x and
here we have something times x so one
way to think about it is that a plus b
needs to be equal to negative 3. the
they need to add up to be this
coefficient so let me write that down
so we have a
plus b
a plus b
needs to be equal to negative three
and we're not done yet we finally look
at this last term we have a times b well
a times b needs to be equal to negative
10. so let's write that down
so we have a times
b
needs to be equal to needs to be equal
to negative 10. and in general whenever
you're factoring something a quadratic
expression that has a
one on the on the quadratic on the
second degree term so it has a one
coefficient on x squared or you don't
even see it but it's implicitly there
you could write this as 1x squared way
to factor is say well can i come up with
two numbers that add up to the
coefficient on the first degree term so
two numbers that add up to negative
three and if i multiply those same two
numbers i'm going to get negative 10. so
two numbers that add up to negative
three to add up to the coefficient here
and now when i multiply it i get the
constant term i get this right over here
two numbers when i multiply i get
negative 10.
well what could those numbers be
well since since when you multiply and
we get a negative number we know that
they're going to have different signs
and so let's see how we could think
about it and since when we add them we
get a negative number we know that the
negative number must be the larger one
so
if i were to just factor 10
i could
you could view that as 1 times 10
1 times 10 or 2 times 5 and 2 and 5 are
interesting because if one of them are
negative their difference is three so if
one is negative so let's see if we're
talking about negative 10
negative 10 you could say negative 2
times 5
and when you multiply them you do get
negative 10 but if you add these two
you're going to get positive 3. but what
if you went positive 2 times negative 5.
now this is interesting because still
when you multiply them you get negative
10 and when you add them
2 plus negative 5 is going to be
negative 3.
so we have just figured out
we have just figured out our two numbers
we could say that a and we could we
could say that a is 2 or we could say
that b is 2 but i'll just say that a is
2.
so a is equal to 2 and b is equal to
negative 5.
b is equal to negative 5.
and so our original expression we can
rewrite as so we can rewrite x squared
minus 3x minus 10. we can say that that
is going to be equal to
x
plus 2
times
x
instead of saying plus negative 5 which
we could say we could just say let me
write that down i could write just plus
negative 5 right over there because
that's our b i could just write x
minus
x minus 5 and we're done we've just
factored it as a product of two
binomials now i did it fairly involved
mainly so you see where all this came
from but in the future whenever you see
a quadratic expression
and you have a one coefficient on the
second degree term right over here you
could say all right well i need to
figure out two numbers that add up to
the coefficient on the first degree term
on the x term and those same two numbers
when i multiply them need to be equal to
this constant term need to be equal to
negative 10. you say okay well let's see
they're going to be different signs
because when i multiply them i get a
negative number the the negative one is
going to be the larger one since when i
add them i got a negative number so
let's see oh see 5 and 2 seem
interesting well negative 5 and positive
2 when you add them you're going to get
negative 3 when you multiply you get
negative 10.